let me say it this way Dave in the words
of the CEO of McDonald's
headquartered in Illinois they are very
concerned not just with the taxes but
with the violence they literally say
people are overdosing in our restaurants
that violent crime is happening in our
restaurants if this is the Chicago and
the Illinois that is in our future
we're concerned that we can't stay
that should have reverberated throughout
all of the country and specifically in
Illinois governor pritzker should have
said OMG McDonald's is now speaking out
about the crime McDonald's is speaking
out about overdoses in their restaurant
whatever I am doing in this state I
should apologize and quit
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
senator from South Carolina as well as
the author of the new book America a
Redemption story choosing hope creating
Unity Senator Tim Scott finally welcome
to the Reuben report well thank you Dave
it's good it's good to be with you thank
you very much for having me I look
forward to our conversation we have lots
to talk about but the good news is I'm
excited to finally be on the show that's
happening
well it goes both ways we've been trying
to get you on for quite some time the
schedules haven't quite matched up but
here we are so let's let's dive right
into it sir because I want to talk about
the book but I obviously want to talk
about current events and election and
and all of that stuff and uh you know
some of the some of the things you're
doing right now but first the the
general point of the book is positivity
it is decency it is something that
seemingly everyone talks about but
nobody does particularly well I include
myself in that sometimes I try to do it
I often fail can you talk a little bit
about how your life LED you to writing
something based in that idea you know
Dave the America Redemption story is a
book that I see as a positive view of
the world as it is not as I hope that it
will be and the truth is that what I
learned through life is that the pain
that I've gone through has helped to
clarify my purpose that my obstacles
have become the opportunities and
frankly the mess I made of my life has
become my message so the truth is that
you yes it's a positive book but it's
not one of those Pie in the Sky hoping
that something will be different than it
is it's the reality of what is there is
a way for us to bring forth a positive
message in the midst of the chaos and
frankly I'm sure we'll talk about
inflation and some of the other
challenges that we see today as the kid
who grew up during the Carter years I
thank God Almighty for Ronald Reagan and
so the truth is that I learned why I
love President Ronald Reagan because of
the misery of high inflation even higher
interest rates and scarcity not a
mentality but at the gas pump so the
truth is that when I think about the
hardest times I've seen in my life
somehow someway a silver lining appeared
and that book talks about that silver
lining and race it talks about it with
the former president it talks about it
in winning and losing elections it talks
about it through this economic challenge
that we're going through right now so I
find the silver lining when it's there
when it's not there I just tell the
blunt truth that it's not there so so it
can be tough to find the silver lining
with so many of the things going on
right now between inflation and supply
chain and the war not war in Ukraine and
a whole bunch of other stuff but do you
think do you really view Us in that
Jimmy Carter moment right now which
maybe could cause you know sort of a red
pilling of Americans the average
American that didn't realize that maybe
big government doesn't work and printed
money doesn't work in the rest of it
well Dave you're you're a you're right
big government has not worked and we
have a history to prove that it doesn't
work uh inflation is led by this one
concept that you talked about
spending money you don't have buying
things you don't need how do we prove
that well 1.9 trillion dollars on a
coveted relief package with one percent
for coveted vaccines that led to pouring
literal gasoline not literal figurative
gasoline on the fire right give them
give them some time when they're getting
rid of strategic reserves yeah and then
you go 1.2 trillion dollars after that
in an infrastructure bill that had 10
percent for roads and bridges over the
next five years you you follow that up
with a
739 billion dollar
Plan called reduction inflation
reduction act and it's really the
inflation acceleration act and not only
does it accelerate inflation but it
actually adds more fuel to the fire by
having the IRS comb through your file so
to speak targeting people under two
hundred thousand dollars a year so the
truth is this is like the Jimmy Carter
years in that
gas is high inflation is high and
interest is creeping up and that's a
problem that causes the recession when
combined with the overspending in
Washington
so anytime I have a republican on
Congressman Senator doesn't matter I
basically ask one question always which
is do you think they are doing this
intentionally do you believe that they
think this stuff works or is this you
know what people are calling sort of
like a calculated implosion Dave that's
a great question I can't say that the
the rank and file Democrats have a
strategy
to have the economy implode because of
the pressure of inflation the pressure
of interest rates what I can tell you is
that the strategy to Slow Roll interest
rate increases had a lot to do from my
perspective of people being up for
reappointment it had something to do
with trying to satisfy the the whims and
the wishes of the Biden Administration
and that combination rather intentional
or not led to an acceleration of
inflation in a way that we haven't seen
since the Carter years so I don't
imagine that they have a grand design to
completely destroy the American economy
I do think they have a grand design to
change the very DNA of the American
people when you look at what's happening
it's undeniable that what is clearly
happening is a centralization in
decision making and in spending when you
take the power and the money and you you
put them in the same place that is by
Design and that is bad for everybody
outside the Beltway
so when you talk to or or if you talk to
say a Democrat Governor maybe uh I just
fled California now I live in the Free
State of Florida if you were to talk to
Gavin newsomware if you have talked to
him or just one of the Democrats Hotel
up in New York Whitmer whoever it might
be yeah I mean do they think what
they're doing is good I mean putting
aside whether it works or not I mean
just the intention I I'm still I'm still
unclear on this I just can't figure it
out well Dave I I have to hope that
their intentions are good I don't know
the mind of the person so I try my best
not to decide whether their intentions
are good or not but what I can tell you
is that if you're living in California
or Illinois let me say this way Dave in
the words of the CEO of McDonald's
headquartered in Illinois they are very
concerned not just with the taxes but
with the violence they literally say
people are overdosing in our restaurants
that violent crime is happening in our
restaurants if this is the Chicago and
the Illinois that is in our future
we're concerned that we can't stay
that should have reverberated throughout
all of the country and specifically in
Illinois governor pritzker should have
said OMG McDonald's is now speaking out
about the crime McDonald's is speaking
out about overdoses in their restaurant
whatever I am doing in this state I
should apologize and quit or if I'm not
going to do those two things apologize
and do a 180 degree turn in the opposite
direction here's what we know works we
know that rule of law works we know that
an objective standard for the rule of
law being applied equally works we know
that no bail doesn't work we know that
defunding the police doesn't work we
know that creating tribalism doesn't
work so if we know these things don't
work why does Gavin Newsom not know that
why does Governor pritzker not know that
I don't have an answer for what's going
through their cranial cavity I can tell
you it's time to stop yes and that's why
I ask you sort of the same question in
two ways because when you see 350 000
people flee California which is what
happened last year you'd think Gavin
might go I don't know maybe this has
something to do with my policies but
okay let's move right right ran to Texas
from California I mean yeah Elon Musk is
now in Texas I mean there there are some
breadcrumbs being left by some really
smart people
they should just pick them up and see
where they lead if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell